mon fils il est mort et sur Powder River
il y a un homme qui essaie d'oublier qu'il a
jamais existé
alors je vais monter là-haut pour lui rappeler
ne t'attends pas à ce que je m'occupe d'un garçon
[Musique]
oh tu vas devoir
mon peuple a vécu ici pendant plus de 2 000 ans les
blancs viennent comme des sauterelles sautillant
les uns sur les autres pour voler des glandes
j'ai juste besoin de quelques acres
vengeance tu n'es pas le seul pour qui
nous marchons David Wellman ne cherche pas
vraiment à être trouvé  mec combien de
temps voyagez-vous avec peut-être que c'est mieux
pour vous de voir le monde car c'est vraiment
nous que j'ai le don de survivre dans un
beau pays tu vas gagner tu ne peux pas
combattre la fourrure tu veux t'amuser
pas tout à fait le  femme je m'attendais
la seule histoire que je puisse raconter est la mienne
ici pour un moment aucun de nous un jour
tu rentreras sans abri ici avec toi
comment nous nous sommes rencontrés pourquoi les
femmes c'était dans les Stars
[Musique]